come and see what everyone's talking
about was his messenger bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaykoum that is the
greeting of peace peace be unto you you
come back here every week and you get to
learn something God wine and we're
thankful and grateful to the creator of
the heavens and earth who's given us
this platform where we can share some of
these truths with you and something that
is on the minds of a lot of the people
is Jesus God
is he the Son of God is he divine now
for me to just tell you this is one
thing but for somebody who is graduated
and mastered this topic who has the
master's in divinity from none other
than the prestigious Harvard University
he finished seminary school he was an
ordained minister our good friend dr.
Gerald Dirk's when we come back he's
going to help us tackle this topic we'll
be right back to sit tight
is his messenger Allah
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe is just to
break the ice a song like my light comes
to that are you doing uh-hum Dalila
praise be to God all right that's good
we're excited here back with us to
tackle this topic is Jesus God but
before we go into that they heard me
mention some of your credentials can you
just briefly talk about a little bit
about your history where you studied in
what you specialized in in school I had
a Bachelor of Arts in philosophy
I was basically pre theology from
Harvard College a Master of Divinity
from Harvard Divinity School I was
ordained into the document in the United
Methodist Church and subsequently went
on and received a masters and a
doctorate in clinical psychology okay so
you know this topic you're qualified to
talk about it that's why we brought you
here
for you to help us clear up this
misconception many people they are being
taught that Jesus is God now can you
tell us what is the evidence where does
this belief come from stem from and is
this true well first of all you know to
say Jesus is God and leave it strictly
at that with adding nothing else is
actually for traditional Christianity a
heresy hmm that is a heretic 'el
statement to make it is a non-christian
statement to make according to
traditional Christianity traditional
Christianity or we look at early
Christianity there were there were three
basic positions that were taken with
regard to the nature of Jesus some early
Christian said Jesus is God
pure and simple now like I said that was
heresy the DOE Sirtis
for example took that position the
second position is Jesus was God and man
simultaneously now this is the
additional Orthodox position of
Christianity stated at the Council of
Chalcedon there were two natures in
Jesus one divine one human and these two
natures were both present but they were
neither mixed nor separated now
something's not mixed and it's not
separated I don't know what's left but
the traditional Creed coming out of
Chalcedon was two natures human and
divine not mixed not separated third
position in early Christianity was that
Jesus was human albeit a man who stood
in a special relationship with God there
was evidence supporting that there was
groups that believed that he was not God
he was purely human absolutely yeah and
these were some of the earlier Christian
sects yeah basically in in terms of
history of Christianity there's a broad
group of early Christians that were
known as subordination as' and by that
it's meant that they subordinated Jesus
to God didn't put them on the same level
and a special interest would be one
particular group of subordination estat
were called adoption US and they were
called adoption estate came to this
concept of the son of God their response
was to say well like an adopted son not
like a physical son more a literal son
yeah so they understood this concept of
son of God in a very metaphorical way
and in fact if we look at the context
and I think we need to look at
historical context when we talk about
this concept of son of God if we look at
the Bible we see that Israel as a whole
the whole of Israel and especially the
sub-tribe of Ephraim were referred to as
the sons of God and you can find this at
home
I'll read them slowly Exodus chapter 4
verse 22 Hosea 11 verses 1 through 3 and
10 3:11 and jeremiah 31 verses 9 and 20
talk about the israelites as a whole in
the tribe of ephraim as being the sons
of god the Bible also tells us that
certain Israelite kings were called the
sons of God so for example David
referred to as the son of God in Psalms
2 verse 7 solomon also referred to as
the son of god and 2nd Samuel 7 verses
13 through 14
angels referred to as the sons of God in
job chapter 1 verse 6 any faithful
person of Israel being referred to as a
son of God in Deuteronomy 14 verse 1 and
finally any righteous man and let me
quote this one it's ecclesiasticus 4
verse 10 ecclesiasticus or the wisdom of
Jesus but Zurich be as a father to
orphans and in a place of a husband to
widows then God will call the son and
will be gracious to thee and deliver
thee from the pit so what we're left
with here and we need to understand this
historical context among the Israelites
in 1st century Palestine to be called
the son of God simply meant you were a
righteous and pious man that's it that's
all it meant now the bible translators
do a trick on people because when they
translate son of god and reference to
jesus christ peace be upon him they put
a capital S in son mm-hmm well in the
Greek there's no capital no lowercase
that's not that's a totally arbitrary
things these legislators are doing some
deception gosslau and then anywhere else
where someone's called the Son of God
they get a lowercase s yeah but that's
the translators that's not in the text
you say that you do not believe in Jesus
you have stepped outside of its name you
can not be a Muslim is that sin in our
faith to believe in and love Jesus
Christ I would say this thing that
you're just told thing it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by a scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
okay like I said earlier we are humbly
trying to express what the truth of
Jesus's message really was and we know
that as ones who have consciously
submitted to the will of God ie Muslims
that we go by the verbatim Word of God
which is unedited unchanged preserved
memorized by millions the verbatim Word
of God and in there it's an article of
our faith to believe in the messengers
Jesus being one of them so if we don't
believe in Jesus you cannot be a Muslim
we love Jesus we respect him we believe
in all these miracles with you you will
that he did you elaborate on this a
little bit further but the Quran says if
you're truthful bring your evidence so
we just want to do what our book is
saying what the creator is saying that
bring your evidence so if we look at the
Bible what are some of the strongest
proves that someone can use because
there are some evidence that some people
will present to justify Jesus being
divine well we can turn to one of them
and that of course is the concept of the
virgin birth as it is portrayed in
Matthew and in Luke this is the process
of divine beginning yeah the problem for
Christians however if they stop and
think about it as we Christians say we
have of God the Father God the Son and
God the Holy Ghost but if Jesus is God
the Son who's his father
well Christians automatically would say
God the Father and yet what the Bible
says in Matthew and Luke is that the
Holy Spirit came upon Mary
not God the Father mmm so who's the one
doing the begetting here that's one
consideration
it's an Islam and the Quran we have the
story of the virgin birth yeah but for
us there's a crucial difference between
the virgin birth is told in the Quran
and the virgin birth is told in Matthew
and Luke and that difference is in the
Quran is not divine beginning it's a
miraculous creation and again I'd like
to just quote those verses from the
Quran but my lord
she cried out that's Mary cried out how
can I have a son when no man has touched
me and so it is that God creates what He
wills the angel replied when he decides
a matter he only has to say be and it is
the example of Jesus and the sight of
God is like that of Adam he created him
from dust saying be and he wants that's
the 3rd chapter of the Quran verses 47
and 59 so a totally different twist this
is a miraculous creation not an act of
divine beginning now Christians point to
the virgin birth and they say divine
beginning they also tend to turn to the
story of the baptism of Jesus mm-hmm as
they find it in the Bible and I'm
turning now to the third chapter of Luke
and this is the baptismal story
basically it says that Jesus goes to
John the Baptist peace be upon them both
he's baptized by John the Baptist and as
he's standing there the skies open up
and the Holy Spirit descends upon him in
bodily form like a dove and then and a
voice came from heaven you are my son
the beloved with you I am well pleased
and many Christians will point to this
verse however as noted in a footnote in
the New Revised Standard Version of the
bye
other ancient authorities read
differently they read you are my son
today I have begotten you as an adult at
the time of the baptism mm-hmm well
under this understanding if you're
begotten is a 37 year old man obviously
the beginning is not to be understood
literally or physically but only
metaphorically at most yes and and point
of fact for Christians who may doubt
that probable original wording of Luke
they can turn to other places in the
Bible and find the same wording in
Hebrews chapter 1 verse 5 Hebrews
chapter 5 verse 5 and reference to Jesus
we have the same morning today I have
begotten thee we also find it in the
thirteenth chapter of Acts the 33rd
verse we have it in the psalms psalms 2
verse 7 being applied to david remember
more than just Jesus was called the Son
of God
so this this notion that Jesus became
the son of God in a motive metaphorical
sense at his baptism was a cardinal
tenant of many early Christian groups
for example the ebee a Knights a very
large Christian group originally in
Palestine they were in existence during
the time of the twelve disciples they
fled from Palestine at the time of the
Romans destroyed the temple and spread
out into Syria Jordan etc and we know
they continued as a viable group of
Christians well into at least the third
century yeah and they were saying no no
Jesus was not God son of God well with a
small s metaphor and Lori he was a
righteous man I'm sorry the debt cetera
but no not in any literal physical sense
it wasn't divine and we know the
disciples the actual disciples of Jesus
also held us them
our view yeah that Jesus was not divine
and we know this because rabbi Gamaliel
who is the president of the Jewish
Sanhedrin ruled officially that the
early Jerusalem Church of James and the
disciples of Jesus was authentically
Jewish and there would be absolutely no
way that the president of the Jewish
Sanhedrin could have ruled at this early
Christian Church in Jerusalem they
continued to worship at the temple was
authentically Jewish if in any way shape
or form they were saying that Jesus was
divine can't wow this is amazing tell us
have you can you expound on this verse
of where it says let us make man in our
image what does this mean well Genesis
is that in Genesis and Genesis I've
heard some Christians when they want to
prove the divinity of how God can be a
man they would say that that let us make
man or in our image what does that mean
well you're going to get different
opinions yeah from from different people
this is one of those very ambiguous
things yeah you know and at a very
primitive level of understanding one
might say that God looks like you and me
yeah but I guess he has a very primitive
primitive level of understanding at a
more abstract level Laemmle one would
say each one of us as human beings is
endowed with the spirit yeah and and
that this is really all that is meant by
in the image of God okay in the
beginning was the word the Word was with
God and the word became flesh this is
somewhere in John 1:1 I first yes first
chapter is John
somebody will throw this in your face
what do you got to say first of all the
prologue of John we know is a later
Edition uh-huh later Edition yeah to the
Gospel of John yeah absolutely
very much influenced by Greek philosophy
in fact I determine logos is very much a
term coming out of Greek philosophy but
the fact that Jesus was pre-existent you
know Islam believes that we were all
preexistent in a spiritual sense that
all the scene of Adam was
before God as in a spiritual sense and
made to affirm the oneness of God so pre
existence of God out of pre existence of
Jesus excuse me there's not in any way
imply divinity mm-hmm and just to remind
you we are here with dr. Gerald Dirk's
who has a master's in divinity from the
prestigious Harvard University has
finished seminary school he's helping us
tackle this topic and you got to know we
love Jesus he was one of the mightiest
messengers of God who called people to
not worship himself but to worship God
alone without any co-equal co-partners
did Jesus ever tell us please did he
ever out of his lips his mouth his
disciples his friends did they ever
teach people or say this word Trinity no
is this Trinity the word anywhere in the
Bible no where we coming up with this
now wow this is this is a later
formulation of Christianity and the
doctrine of the Trinity grew in fits and
starts
it basically grew out of Pauline
Christianity as it emerged and developed
in Europe this concept of Trinity or the
divinity of Jesus did not develop
typically in the Christianity that was
developing in North Africa and in the
Middle East
here again we had this adoption astre
jek turi where people understood son of
God to be metaphorical you know Jesus
moved into a special relationship with
God as we would expect a prophet and
messenger to do absolutely yeah and and
so we have a long history of this
adoption astray in early Christianity
Theodotus the Gnostic and the second
century was preaching this adoption
esteem notice to Tanner
later in the second century and and his
teaching developed of what was called
Theodosia nism or dynamic my mark
Ian ISM lasted well into the third
century Oregon third century priest
also was teaching a subordination
Astoria DAPs inist Christology teaching
the oneness of God not right unity no no
Trinity no Trinity that Jesus was
clearly subordinate to God Dionysos
third century bishop bishop mind you and
alexandria again teaching that jesus was
the adopted son of God or subordinate to
God Paul of Samos odda third century
Bishop of Antioch also teaching this
message st. Lucian of Antioch third
century theologian teaching this message
so you can see this is quite widespread
in the Middle East and in North Africa
and then finally arias fourth century
priest and founder of
arianism it was in Alexandria Egypt and
his movement lasted well into the
seventh century mhm
in North Africa and the Middle East in
fact many Christian and I historians
would say that arianism this particular
form of adoptionism was the majority
element in Christianity during the
fourth century so this is quite quite a
statement and and it's interesting to
look at what areas actually taught and
as to not mistake I'm on to just read
this areas taught that God is absolutely
unique and incomparable his alone self
existent unchangeable and infinite and
must be understood in terms of his
absolute oneness given this
all-important first premise arias
concluded that one the life of Jesus has
portrayed and the canonical Gospels
demonstrates that Jesus was not self
existent that he changed and grew over
time if in no other way than in passing
through the stages of birth childhood
adolescence
in adulthood and that he was finite
having a definite time of conception and
birth
therefore arias concluded Jesus was
God's created being who was pulled into
existence out of nothingness who could
not have shared in the absolute
uniqueness immutability and infinity of
God without compromising them who could
not have been of the same substance as
God without compromising the oneness of
God and who could have had no direct
knowledge of God other than that which
God chose to reveal to them now as
Muslims I think affirm what area is the
same mean absolutely that God is one
he's not his creation he has no
beginning he has no end he's not a man
he's not Jesus that God is one he's not
his creation he has no beginning he has
no end he's not a man he's not Jesus
this is what we're saying yes what all
the messengers talk yes and this is what
arias was teaching this is what the
adoption is basically we're teaching
though arias as is perhaps the one who
elaborated this to the best possible
extent but but it doesn't end here I'm
telling you Eusebius of Nicomedia fourth
century bishop and a comedian also an
adoption Asst Macedonia's fourth century
patriarch of constantinople arguably the
number two men and all of Christendom
behind only the Pope and the Greek
Orthodox would say equal to the Pope
mm-hmm he was an adoption when you say
adoption is what do you mean this is
someone who maintained that would we say
Jesus is the Son of God we mean like an
adopted son like metaphorically yeah
like we're saying is righteous not
literal yeah not physical yeah but
someone who moved into a special
relationship with God all the prophets
had a special relation me absolutely
yeah
and the last and final messenger the
same thing that used to be upon him so
tell us this is very interesting
and I'm sure that those humble people
sincere people are really getting
enlightened with all this new
information that many people just they
haven't been taught and you haven't
graduated from Harvard with a master's
in divinity finished with a the seminary
school this is like that graduate above
going into more profoundly of the
history of the Bible and all the other
early manuscripts tell us through the
early sects of Christianity because the
Quran the verbatim Word of God tells us
that all the prophets were those who
called to the oneness of God they
submitted themselves you could take this
concept in French and Japanese and
whatever but it's summed up with one
word Islam that they all did Islam were
these earlier sects did they seem like
what you're telling me that they were on
Islam yes name some more or less more or
less oh we can go on from Macedonia's to
ids 4th century Bishop of Antioch and
I'm just naming prominent people bishops
etc Nestorius 5th century bishop of
constantinople again patriarch of
constantinople and founder of
nestorianism a christian movement that
lasted well into the ninth century yeah
in China Theodora mop Celestia who is
the fifth century guardian of right
faith of the Persian church Saint
clotilda if in 6th century princess of
Burgundy all adoption is now what
happened was that areas and Arianism
became so popular that it threatened to
pull Christianity apart and at this time
constantine who's the emperor of rome is
sitting on a fairly shaky throne yeah
and to secure his place politically in
313 he issued the Edict of Milan which
legalized Christianity for the first
time in the Roman
well this got him the support of the
Christians obviously so that helps the
curious phone a bit more but the
conflict that was emerging within
Christianity about what's the nature of
Jesus was threatening to tear apart that
that part of his coalition and so
Constantine called for the Council of
Nicaea in the year 325 they called the
bishop said we want you to come but sort
this out let's figure out what's the
nature of Jesus well first of all a lot
of bishops didn't show I mean they
weren't going to travel to Nicaea which
is a modern-day Turkey and submit to
this sort of the council with
Constantine soldiers gathered all around
here so a lot of people didn't go those
who went to defend areas they basically
were placed under a lot of pressure many
of them who voted for what came to be
known as the Nicene solution later
recanted as soon as they went back home
but constant could imagine the pressure
probably outs with the guards and this
atmosphere 19 as it turns out was
actually an adoption us when he was
actually later baptized later in life he
was baptized by Eusebius of Nicomedia
and Miriam so he was an adoption Asst
but the adoption is a most centered in
the Middle East and in Egypt in North
Africa Constantine is looking for allies
closer to home yeah and the closest one
the home is the Bishop of Rome or what
later came to be known as the Pope and
the Bishop of Rome was very much in this
camp of Jesus's both God and man
simultaneously and so Constantine sort
of sold out his own beliefs for
political power and made an alliance
with the Bishop of Rome and coming out
of the Council of Nicaea was this
statement that Jesus and God are of the
same substance now this is starting to
get us towards the Trinity but Nicaea
still didn't say anything about the Holy
Spirit really
so Jesus and God are of the same
substance how unpopular was this
decision sixteen years later
3:41 of the council of antioch the
assembled bishops basically said we're
not going to touch this question and so
they're creedal formulation said nothing
about any relationship between god and
jesus they were begging off the question
and sixteen years after that and 357 at
the council of sirmium the assembled
bishops actually voted decreed which
said that jesus is not of the same
substance as god now if you look at the
decision of the Council of sirmium in
the year 357 the official position of
Christianity was Jesus and God are not
with the same substance it was only if
the second ecumenical council of
constantinople and the Year 381 that the
so called Nicene Creed was actually
issued and it is that the Council of
Constantinople in 381 that the Nicene
Creed came out not at the Council of
Nicaea in 325 so then this was a hotly
debated issue what's the nature of Jesus
and as I said before a majority of
Christians in the fourth century were
adoption us now a person may say okay
what happened to these adoptions why why
don't we see him around today well in
point of fact we do the Jehovah
Witnesses claim that they're followers
of areas and the Unitarians is
originally formulated also playing
they're followers of areas but the main
reason we don't see Aryans today or
adoption as today as we need to look at
where they were centered they were
centered in North Africa they were
centered in the Middle East and they
basically died out in the seventh
century now why did they die out in the
seventh century I would submit to you
the reason was the message that was
brought by Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him these people were so closely
aligned with what we have come to call
Islam that in the seventh century they
naturally converted in mass into Islam
we're going to have to do a part two
they're signaling that we're out of time
for this session and we're going
have to continue on this is very
intriguing and lightning and can we
continue on a part - sure inshallah okay
we're going to take a break and we're
gonna try to come back and do a part two
so next week come back where we continue
talking about is Jesus divine that he
say he was divine as you can see that
evidence is pointing toward him not
being divine that he was indeed a
Messenger of God this is what his
disciples those around him his
companions believed and all the plethora
of evidence of the early Christians and
what the last and final messenger the
Prophet Muhammad came with the verbatim
would have Quran which clears all this
doubt off about him and tells you that
he was indeed one of the mightiest
messengers of gas we're gonna continue
on talking about this mighty messenger
Jesus to clear up his name so come back
next week here on the Deen show and
we'll continue talking about this with
our good friend brother dr. Gerald
Derrick's he created the universe to him
alone the heavens and
they'll believe it he is the first he's
the on the Mercedes and his messengers
to mourn his creatures of the great
dangers a worshipping of God and Allah
there is none greater creator